with the January 6 hearings happening
throughout June one person who is
actively trying to avoid their questions
is Peter Navarro he was charged by the
doj for ignoring two subpoenas from the
January 6 committee then he filed a suit
against the committee and the doj and
now in a true trump-like grifting
fashion he's on TV begging for money for
his legal fund
[Music]
former Trump adviser and infomercial
salesman trying to sell you money Making
Secrets Peter Navarro just to catch
everyone up to speed Peter Navarro was
one of the key authors of the plan to
overturn the result of the 2020 election
one of the others was Steve Bannon you
know the guy who looks like he's a mix
between dandruff and a Rotten Tomato
Navarro was charged by the doj with two
counts for contempt of congress for his
refusal to comply with the January 6
committee the first charge was for
refusing to appear for a deposition and
the second charge was for failing to
provide information on the Green Bay
sweep Navarro outlines the Green Bay
sweep in his book taking back Trump's
America why we lost the White House and
how we'll win it back Jesus Christ that
has got to be the world record for
longest book title he stated that the
sweep was designed as the last best
chance to snatch a stolen election from
the Democrats jaws of Deceit Navarro
said the plan was to have lawmakers on
Capitol Hill debate the Electoral
results from six swing states in the
hope of having Congress declare the
results to be in dispute Navarro claimed
that President Trump was on board with
the strategy and then up to a hundred
Congress men were committed to executing
the plan however the plan was dependent
on vice president Mike Pence who opted
not to participate you know the same
Mike Pence that all of Trump's followers
wanted to hang on January 6 during the
insurrection
oh a awkward oh and by the way Trump was
totally okay with that happening anyway
Navarro has been claiming that the
January 6 committee is a sham and that
he is completely innocent despite the
fact that he goes on TV and openly
admits his involvement in trying to
overturn the election most recently he
was on Ari melber show risking going
potentially to jail
not to talk to them but you're out here
talking in public
you do realize these investigators can
hear you when you talk on TV in the very
next day Navarro was arrested by the FBI
wow I guess karma is a real thing all
right is it just me or has anyone else
noticed a theme with Navarro's outfit
because every time I see him on Newsmax
or Fox News or Ari melber show he's
always wearing the same outfit white
shirt rolled up sleeves and a tie
Navarro reminds me of a high school
basketball coach whose team is down by
20 in the fourth quarter with three
seconds to go and in a moment of
desperation he pulls out a whiteboard
and tells us that we need to drive up
the middle and give Trump the ball to
win the game this guy is an absolute
joke but actually now that I think about
it I've seen this look before he reminds
me of Jim Cramer you know one's a
traitor and the other
is a traitor so in the spirit of this
segment let's make a quick adjustment
much better from day one Navarro has
claimed he was protected by executive
privilege well guess what he doesn't
have it so Navarro then appears to fall
back on the vague assertion that the
executive privilege here belongs to
former president Trump which is not only
dubious but entirely irrelevant because
our committee has not been given any
attempted invocation of executive
privilege by Donald Trump Navarro
reminds me of George Costanza's dad just
throwing up his arms and exclaiming
executive privilege now so when Navarro
would dress reporters after being
indicted by a grand jury for contempt of
congress charges he complained about how
he was treated unfairly and had to stay
in John Hinckley Jr cell
which is a weird thing to brag about
instead of calling me and say hey we
need you down at court
we've got a warrant for you I would have
gladly come what did they do they
intercepted me getting on the plane and
then they put me in handcuffs they bring
me here they put me in leg irons wait
what was that they intercepted me
getting on the plane and then they put
me in handcuffs they bring me here they
put me in leg irons leg irons Navarro
was Notorious for lying again the guy
tried to overturn the 2020 election so
while Lake irons on Navarro would be a
great thing to see I highly doubt they
put more than handcuffs on the guy and
to anyone out there who doubts me get me
photos of Navarro and leg irons Navarro
says he would have gladly shown up if
they had asked and to that and I say
[ __ ] Navarro was arrested at a DC
area airport while attempting to fly to
Nashville to meet with a former Arkansas
Governor Mike Huckabee aka the wish.com
version of Ernest Hemingway Navarro uses
more green screen backgrounds than
Hollywood Blockbuster films so excuse me
if I don't believe Navara or Huckabee
about flying to do an interview when he
does all of them from his basement no
Navarro is 100 of Flight Risk and then
in true Navarro fashion he went on to
Tucker Carlson's entertainment show to
cry some more instead they went with his
shock and awe terrorist strategy yeah
let me go to the airport and then then
take me with five agents like I'm a
Al-Qaeda terrorist maybe this is Navarro
projecting and he thinks he actually is
a terrorist I don't know I mean he did
try to overturn a fair and safe election
and now Navarro is begging for money by
asking people to buy his book it's the
same one that I mentioned earlier with
the really long title my book taking
back Trump's America I need everybody in
America to buy that book on Amazon
taking back Trump's America Jesse
because that book is going to be my
legal defense it's on Amazon this book
taking back Trump's America help me
please I do not want to spend several
hundred thousand dollars on lawyers well
this is going to cost a half a million
dollars I'm looking at a half a million
dollars in legal expenses According to
some legal experts or more this could go
to a million that's going to basically
wipe out my retirement savings and I'll
be eating dog food Navarro's next court
appearance is set for June 17th so who
knows maybe we'll find out more details
about who or what Navara was covering
for and hopefully the January 6
committee will have those details to
share with us or Navarro just admits to
his crimes during an upcoming TV
interview because if there was anyone
who could talk themselves into a jail
sentence it's Peter Navarro well I'm
Gabe Sanchez and this has been what was
that
[Music]